[Music]
my whole thing is whenever I'm whenever
I'm we get something wherever I'm scared
of something I master it
I was a weak ma you know a weak-minded
person so I mastered my mind and it
matched in my mind I mastered the human
mind and I realized why I'm no longer
just people why I don't like I put
people in a pedestal
cuz we're all [ __ ] up around way we
all have demons some people hide them
better than other people so I know we
all have them by me knowing that under
the most alpha males are very fragile
very fragile they never want to see
another person harder than them
especially in that kind of round you go
attach the ego honor is strong ego will
[ __ ] you up every time ego was serious
so if I can hurt your ego
I got you so by me having such a fragile
ego growing up all this was my event I
was doing a live autopsy on how [ __ ]
up I was I was like hey this [ __ ] me up
I better [ __ ] other people up too so I
started using all these different tools
and tactics to getting instructors heads
and taking souls that's what happened
man we were Wednesday freezing [ __ ]
cold
everybody's jackhammer and everybody's
everybody wants to you know everybody's
just want to get through it now
jackhammer ends when you just can't stop
she can't stop shivering you know you're
sitting this uncontrollable
jackhammering and the instructors take
great pride in watching you suffer they
do we're you know in in a sick way it's
kind of funny you know you know you were
there once as a student now your
instructor but I knew how would I be
thinking house in this trust I would
love seeing this sadistic [ __ ] go on but
what went out what wouldn't I like to
see I would hate to see some guys just
looking like this is just another
[ __ ] day on the [ __ ] beach and go
[ __ ] yourself I would hate to see that
so as I don't want to think like that
when they did it they were harder they
were harder everybody's horas I see know
what man it's time you all I can't fight
you
you guys can [ __ ] me up all day long
that's your job and I love your job I
love what you guys are doing you guys
making this better but now I want to
take the tactical advantage I'm gonna
start [ __ ] with you so I got my boat
crew
brown-eyed Chris Kyle my boat crew
American I've had a couple of hardcore
[ __ ] and everybody right now is
kind of like in their own world let's
just get through this man I can't wait
til Friday so we can graduate how we can
get going I said let's go ahead and have
some fun
I said we're gonna start [ __ ] with these
guys so the evolution here was we got to
with Matt check you know we're stripped
down to nothing and they're checking us
out making sure we're good to you know
check in front of Mon you're checking
for [ __ ] up knees my knees all jacked
up but they're giving me shots and [ __ ]
and I was like the boat crew leader of
boat crew tune so I'm in the front the
boat and I tell our guys this we're
going to do the boats like on our heads
salt was we're supposed to lift the
boats up above her head so I got dude
but when you're this week in this
fragile you this tired their boats heavy
so there's a thing you can do when you
do boat presses so you can get the boat
like this toss it up toss it up and
catch it and that shows like you're
jacked up so everybody's holding the
boat and they're shaking and both
starting to come down their head and all
the boat crews are all lined up and
they're [ __ ] up now I'm looking at
that and I turn around my book I said
guys it's time to [ __ ] take some
Souls anybody what the [ __ ] you talking
about I said I could see all these
[ __ ] instructors out here all on
their [ __ ] jackets and drinking
coffee and laughing and smiling [ __ ] I
want their [ __ ] faces to go straight
up [ __ ] numb so we're gonna do this
we're gonna start boat pressing this
[ __ ] just take my lead trust me
you'll get energy from it which are
throwing this boat up in the [ __ ] air
cache the toilet for kiss and Chuck
yelling I can't her [ __ ] boat crew -
we're yelling or [ __ ] ass off and we
do it and they make a stop like what the
[ __ ] let me stop I look at these
instructors and their faces literally
look like someone like just like took
their soul oh god no other minds were
like they were thinking about themselves
like what the [ __ ] just happy man I know
me almost I could've done that
how they doing it so the rest of time
going through hell week it was like we
just you know we owned it right boat
crew - we won every single race we were
just dominating and it was uh there's a
strong boat crew and that's we're taking
souls is uh there's a few taking soil
stories but that's one of them so I like
this idea
you know doing taking this inventory
tool and applying it to how you're
spending your time throughout the day
you know I talk about this a lot you
went into detail in this challenge about
look man if you if you actually write
down how you're spending your time
throughout the day over a seven day
period I mean it's crazy because I
thought I was being pretty efficient
with my time and I've done this and it's
just amazing how much time is wasted
that you're not even consciously aware
of unreal how much time you waste during
the day and most of it is on these
[ __ ] computers phones you know
instagramming back-and-forth whatever
the hook you call [ __ ] nowadays tweeting
and texting the [ __ ] we waste so much
time on our little gadgets it's unreal
and we talked about we have no time if
you really think you have to take your
day and write write down this one day
everything you do write that down and
you like my god I am wasting so much
time on frivolous [ __ ] not funny I
mean it will if it doesn't infuriate you
it should because there's so much time I
can't get it in look at your schedule
just wasted seven hours a day on
[ __ ] I mean you'll have an hour a
day to try to get something in for
yourself
I guarantee everybody can find an hour
then it becomes about willingness yeah
because most people just they're not
willing to get up that early
to you know make those sacrifices
required so it's a function of how badly
do you want to change your life and what
are you willing to endure to craft that
life that you aspire to have or do you
just want to talk about it yeah I mean
it's [ __ ] miserable it is miserable I
mean to get up every day or five days a
week whatever when it's snowing Sahni
not not shiny not not comfortable and to
go into gym and workout when you don't
want to go to gym it is not fun well and
we're in a culture that that is driving
everybody towards this idea that
happiness is purchased through luxury
comfort and ease the truth could not be
no more different from that reality that
if you want to find peace with yourself
self understanding self knowledge self
esteem all of these things are going to
be found only through sacrifice getting
uncomfortable
reevaluating what your normal is and
putting yourself in situations that you
don't want to [ __ ] do yes and we want
it very fast if you don't see results in
the first two days or the first week I'm
done that's the mentality of most people
their struggle is too real we're not
patient we like in the world where you
can google the best restaurants around
me right now no one is patient and for
you to lose weight for you to stop drink
if you where the hell you're going
through it takes a lot of patience a lot
of time and a lot of pitfalls a lot of
plateaus you hit so many [ __ ]
plateaus if you'll know how to get
around that plateau it's not gonna
happen fast mm-hmm yeah everybody wants
the hack yeah everybody wants to hey
there is no hack man there's no hack
what do you think is the biggest
stumbling block that most people face
with this kind of journey honestly is
they have the woe is me mentality it's
too hard life isn't fair these things in
life are not easy for me you you you
look to your left you look to your right
and you start to judge yourself off
other people like if you're a female
well she's skinny and she doesn't work
out as hard as I do and everything
starts to corrupt your mind you start to
look around too much of other people
what they're doing and that starts to
corrupt your own dialogue we are judging
ourselves against too many [ __ ]
people you have to judge yourself
against yourself and that's the one
thing I started learning man this is the
race against me and rich roll this is
race against david Goggins and david
Goggins alone if once you can silence
all that [ __ ] all the outside
interference and things that are
attracting your mind to everything you
can then start to grow and realize and
I'm stressed out for no reason this is
my own little race
there's my own time line and this time
I'm gonna run it you gotta go to war
with yourself before there's peace
that's what I say in the bush you say in
the book you must go to war yourself
before you find peace so I'm trying to
give you tools on how to do that and I'm
not gonna smile and be happy about it
it's a hard journey it's a real journey
it's a it's a journey that's gonna take
way outside of being comfortable if you
want to be great want to be bashed
[ __ ] ever at what you do
you could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're gonna be so [ __ ]
obsessed and so driven to get there
that's what it takes that's the trip
takes every second of your [ __ ] life
anybody says balance yeah balance is
important for a lot of [ __ ] people it
is but if you want to [ __ ] go to that
edge where people do not like you don't
understand you question everything you
[ __ ] do you you've arrived when you
are misunderstood to the point where
[ __ ] people think you're psycho and
you're nuts and you're this and that why
are you in the [ __ ] gym at one
o'clock in the [ __ ] morning you've
got through doing an OP for [ __ ] 13
14 hours at the Ranger school man
at the gym what's wrong you will never
understand what is wrong with me and
that's why I'm so [ __ ] glad you don't
cuz I'm in the right [ __ ] spot when
people don't understand you anymore
you're in that spot of obsession and
Drive where people have quit the [ __ ] is
wrong this guy I want to talk to you man
cuz you're not gonna get it you're not
gonna get it
boom I want you to get it yeah I want
you to get it yeah that's powerful man
Roger that man so I bought my set yeah
that's it man you have to change the
dialogue with in your head and one thing
I guarantee you there's some stat out
there about January 1 all that kindling
that you started or that motivation
usually burn out by about 10 to 12 days
later so see how far you can take that
[ __ ] let's see if you can get a [ __ ]
there's a challenge from Goggins do you
usually is 10 to 12 days man people
always come in man hey I want to work
out program I no longer give them
anymore cuz you go waste my [ __ ] time
good I know most people out there once
that [ __ ] one alarm clock goes off
the wrong time of the day I'm not going
to the gym right or they get the workout
program but then they're like hey they
hit you up again what kind of watch do I
need to guess right that's not shoes as
rush you just keep coming every may goes
by without anything going on keep coming
go to the store buy a pair of shoes and
Merry Christmas have fun with that [ __ ]
call me after you lose some [ __ ]
weight running your ass in the dirt and
you
got some other [ __ ] well I met my my
knucks husband and I'd never heard of
Lutheran's except for I guess maybe
Garrison Keillor like I had never I
didn't know what a Lutheran HUS and and
he was like really involved in like
Christian social justice and I was like
[ __ ] is like what that's a thing I think
it just seemed I'd never heard those two
things go together and so he sort of
introduced me to more progressive form
of Christianity and I was just I was
just fascinated that that even existed
and you know we moved out to California
and I vary but grudgingly started going
to this Lutheran Church that had this
gay pastor and going to this adult
confirmation class at night and just I
just soaked it up I I had no idea that
you could believe those things I none so
it was like the thing I still loved
which was Jesus plus stuff that seemed
just real and genuine and like easy to
believe because I knew already know it
was true like when they said we're
simultaneously Center and saying I'm
like [ __ ] man that that explains a lot
that's super helpful thanks guys and
then what what compels you to go to
Divinity School and welcome a pastor
it's there were two two things the first
time I had that hit of oh I think I have
like quote a calling was when my friend
PJ committed suicide and he was a puka
comic and also in recovery and I had not
been to Divinity School or seminary at
this point but when PJ died our friends
just turned to me and we were like well
you could do the funeral right and just
literally cuz I was the only religious
person in my friend group the only thing
that qualified me and I said okay and it
it was like this it was at the comedy
works in downtown Denver and it was
packed and I was giving his eulogy and I
just looked out and there were all these
like academics and comics and queers and
recovering alcoholics and I just thought
mandis these people do not have a pastor
and then I went [ __ ] gonna have to be
you oh damn you know so that was my
first hit about that like trying to
notice a sense of being called yeah well
I I felt called to be a pastor to my
people not to fit in some box that the
institutional Church has for if that's a
job you want you know what I mean those
are two different things right like you
could minister to these people in a way
that no one else that you knew could I
think that we need load-bearing
structures you know and that's what
religion it's been this is the first
time we've had cultures that weren't
religious like in human history so there
was a way in which religion was a
load-bearing structure in terms of
understanding who we were understanding
morality having a symbol system for for
imaging the divine for marking the year
together there's a function that that
religion has played in in throughout
human history that I feel like even
though the institutions of religion have
heard a lot of people I just think it's
just not time to dispense with that idea
entirely and it's a really recent idea
in human history that you can just
choose your own symbol system that's
that's new well the foundations of
religion are are crumbled you know and
there's a there's a you know a crisis of
trust in those structures and those
institutions which i think is why people
are like well i feel like i can i'm i
like to listen to Nadia well I think
there's just because I really do try to
be very forthcoming with my shortcomings
and with things I've gotten wrong or
should I don't know you know there's not
the curtain so much yeah there's nothing
you're gonna like find out that's good
right like at one point I was like
that's also like something that you
learn in in a totally like own those
flaws and and you know find the
empowerment and the vulnerability and to
not actually have shame about it I mean
that's the thing is like I believe in
the power of grace so strongly that I
have no shame in admit
why I need it mm-hmm so then people feel
like they can trust what I'm saying also
like self-incrimination is like my go-to
rhetorical move and that allows me to be
more horrible to people because I'm nice
to you but now you can connect with you
listen I've heard you speak it's very
you know it's not just it's it's a it's
a it's a incredible experience to hear
you speak and I can feel myself
connected to the message that you're
putting out there and it makes me
reflect back on my experience as a young
person going to church and just sitting
in these pews thinking what am I doing
here I can't believe I understand what
they're talking about I'm falling asleep
why is that guy swinging that rope with
the terrible-smelling stuff that was
dressed up no I like I'm an Episcopalian
yeah like an elementary school I just
found the whole thing totally bizarre
and I was like he used about what I was
supposed to get out of it it wasn't that
I had it wasn't that I was traumatized
by it I just didn't understand it and I
didn't understand why everyone felt
compelled to go like I was getting
nothing out worded to any of it in times
of crisis at all not in a in a in an
organizational structured yeah in a
non-denominational kind of spiritual way
yeah you know I found God in the rooms
of Alcoholics Anonymous and my spiritual
growth as as you know taking me through
you know an exploration of many
different types of faith and and
experiences and practices and teachers
and the like and I haven't settled into
one particular perspective on that but
I've learned from all of them yeah yeah
well one thing that Esther said I'm just
quoting like smarter women though myself
um she said that that it's easy that the
one of the things that religion offers
is that in times of of crisis and of
pain when we're collapsing there's
something to hold us like like it's easy
to come up with rituals and practices
and stuff in times of birth or weddings
but when [ __ ] hits the fan
there's something there to hold you that
there are these sort of rituals or
prayers that have been worn smooth by
generations of the faithful in a way
that can kind of bring us comfort when
you can't just create your own thing on
the spot when you're in a position of
crisis and pain I thought can that the
can can you have that connection without
the baggage that comes with the incident
that's the question that's literally the
question right now I mean I when I left
Christianity for a decade
I couldn't have anything to do with it I
was you know after I left the church I
was very used and so when people say
like but a lot of us have to leave for
for reasons of self-preservation like I
get that I ever judge it but I think
that there is a path to integrating our
religious upbringing rather than
rejecting that eventually there's that
kind of work that can be done - even if
it's just you know there's this prayer
my grandmother said when I was going to
sleep every night that's still really
meaningful and I'm gonna integrate that
into my life you know yeah that that
that's a part of wellness to me to be
able to do that so I've been just sort
of inviting people into considering what
that might look like and it doesn't have
to be a betrayal of the part of you that
needed to reject it for good reason to
say yeah but it still formed Who I am on
some level and I want to make friends
with that part of me say something to
the person who's listening who who
doesn't have a connection with faith or
perhaps like lost their connection with
faith in whatever tradition they find
themselves and like what is it about
faith and connection that that you find
to be so important as part of the human
condition and how can that person find
their way back to a place of
incorporating that into their
well in a way it's not like a super
popular sentiment but I just I don't
feel like I'm enough in a sense that I
do think having a power that's more than
just me and accessing that is has
transformed my life and that that's
possible and available for anyone
regardless of what they believe or what
sort of you know faith they have that
that there are things that accessing
like having a connection to our source
and to the divine allows us to undergo a
certain type of healing and
transformation that would be very
difficult for us to do just as our own
on our own as individuals so that's the
power of it to me and and there are
things like people who are raised
religious and had to leave sometimes
there are still like hymns that are dear
to them or prayers their grandmother
said or whatever and I think just
finding those things and integrating
them back into our lives on our own
terms can be really healing and it's
like this spiritual reclamation project
and and it's okay to do that it's who
you are and it's fine because your
symbol system forms you in a way that's
hard to escape so making friends with it
on your own terms as an adult can be
yeah it could be doing it's important to
think about this so this this extremely
strong scientific evidence that there
are three kinds of cause of depression
and anxiety and to some degree they play
out in in in fact all forms of mental
and emotional problems so there's
biological cause is like your genes like
real brain changes that happen when you
become depressed that can make it
somewhat harder to get out those are
real right there are people who deny
them they are definitely wrong the
evidence is very clear on that there are
psychological causes which are how you
think about yourself and there are
social causes which are how we live
together and these are all real but what
we've done is we largely as a culture
told a story that focuses exclusively on
the biology right they can
my doctor told me there's just a problem
in your brain the problem with that
well the first probably days is not true
right but the second problem that is
what it tells people is your distress
doesn't mean anything it's like a glitch
in a computer program and someone who
really helped me to think a bit
differently about this I went to
interview this South African
psychiatrist called Derrick Sommerfeld
he's a wonderful man and he happened to
be in Cambodia in 2001 when they
introduced chemical entity process for
the first time - for the people in that
country and the local doctors the
Cambodian doctors had never heard of
these drugs so they were like why are
they and he explained and they said oh
we don't need them we've already got
antidepressants and he said what do you
mean he thought they were going to talk
about some kind of herbal remedy like
sand john's wort or something
instead they told him a story there was
a farmer in their community who one day
stood on a landmine and got his leg
blown off and he worked in the rice
fields so they gave him an artificial
limb and he went back to work in the
rice fields after I forget what it was
some months but apparently it's very
painful to work underwater with an
artificial leg I'm guessing it was
traumatic for obvious reasons the guy
started to cry all day didn't want to
get out of bed developed classic
depression they said to dr. something
well that's when we gave him an
antidepressant and he said wow they
explained that they went and sat with
him they listened to him they realized
that his pain made sense they figured if
they put him a cow he could become a
dairy farmer he wouldn't be in this
position that was screwing him up so
much so they bought in the cow with a
couple of weeks his crying stopped
within a month his depression was gone
they said to dr. Sommerfeld so that cow
that was an antidepressant that's what
you mean right now if you've been raised
to think about this the way we have that
sounds like a joke I went to my doctor
for an antidepressant he gave me a cow
but what those Cambodian doctors knew
intuitively is what the leading medical
body in the world the World Health
Organization has been trying to tell us
for years
if you're depressed if you're anxious
you're not crazy you're not a machine
with broken parts you're a human being
with unmet needs and what you need is
practical love and support from the
people around you to get those deeper
needs met it's a very different way of
talking about these problems it explains
to people their pain is a signal it
means something it
for a reason is telling you your needs
aren't being met or some other things
and obviously reference to a pile or
there's some you know psychological
event that occur that you haven't really
fully processed or worked through
there's some there's some hitch in your
operating system that that requires
redress and what I wouldn't say
operating system I was experiencing the
grief in the law and the loss of a loved
one or something like like yes there are
natural reactions that you know we've
kind of been told we should just get
over that kind of stuff rather than
really just embrace them for what they
are because that is that is what it is
to be human and that's certainly fine
and to stigmatize that or just to kind
of pathologize that as certain and
certainly wrong but they're there their
messages their wake-up calls that if
this signal yeah yeah you need to do
that and I think to go back to the
cultural piece you know someone's
grieving the loss of a loved one and
they're uncomfortable sitting with that
grief we have a system that's set up to
help you and say you don't need to feel
this way like take this take this pill
right because we've gotten to a place
where it's almost understood that we
never need to feel bored or
uncomfortable or ill at ease right that
we can that we can just medicate all of
that and and implicit in that is this
idea that we should all be happy all the
time I think people are right to want to
be happy and satisfied in their lives
the question is is a deeper thing that
you're getting out which is so let's
think about grief for example there was
this thing that happened in the 1970s
that I think is really revealing so in
the 1970s the APA the American
Psychiatric Association who had them
obviously the main body of psychiatrist
in the US and psychologists decided to
do kind of basic kind of obvious thing
they decided they've got a standardized
how depression was diagnosed across the
u.s. so up to their doctors were just
basically deciding for themselves though
what what depression meant so the APA
dropper check is simple checklist of 10
symptoms
of these things crying a lot you know
you could guess them so it's 10 simple
there's 10 list of 10 symptoms and they
send it to doctors all over the United
States and they say if your patient
shows more than five of these 10
symptoms for more than two weeks and
diagnose them as mentally ill and do
what you can so they send this out but
within a quite a short period afterwards
psychiatrist start to come back and go
I've got a bit of a problem here if we
use this checklist and the way you're
telling us to we're going to have to
diagnose every grieving person in the
United States as depressed because these
are also the symptoms of grief and the
APA got together and they said that's
not all we men clear we didn't intend
that so they invented something that
became known as the grief loophole where
they said okay if your patients come to
you and they've got more than five of
these 10 symptoms for more than two
weeks diagnosed as mentally ill unless
someone they love has died in the last
year in which case it doesn't count the
only exception of crazy what exactly
they started doing this but this began
to beg the question hang on a minute
why is someone you love dying what we're
saying is what we're meant to tell dr.
Monteux people is so if you feel this
way it's just a problem in your brain
that just needs to be drugged into
submission except there is one
circumstance in life where it's an
understandable response but why is that
the only circumstance why if my mother
dies I'm allowed to feel like that but
not if I lose my job why not if I become
homeless why not if I'm stuck in a job I
hate for the next 40 years right but
what that does is a wonderful woman
called dr. Joanne cassia Tory is the
leading expert on traumatic grief in the
United States has read an amazing work
on this asking well once you acknowledge
that depression can be largely a
response to life that just challenges
the whole system we've built the system
we've built is not designed to talk
about context it's not designed to talk
about how do we sit with you and hold
you and love you and help you change
your life right as she puts it we just
don't understand pain in this culture
we've developed a bizarre way of talking
about pain it's so bizarre that I didn't
interview recently on a radio show and
where I was talking about we were
talking before in a similar way to the
way between before about loneliness
causing depression and the interview
said to me well this is an extra
controversial theory and I thought how
do we get to the point where it was
regarded as controversial to point out
the most banal and obvious thing which
is if you're lonely you're going to be
much more likely to be acutely unhappy
and butBut so I think the grief
exception debate reveals something
really deep about how we have
misunderstood payment so Jerrod dr.
cassia Toure it'd be great person for
you to talk to and give an intro to
she's an extraordinary woman and her
baby died during birth her daughter
Cheyenne and she was devastated and she
was horrified to be to see how many
other grieving parents were very rapidly
being diagnosed as mentally ill and and
drug-drug because the APA was so
uncomfortable with this debate about the
grief loophole they just got rid of it
doesn't exist anymore right so now you
can be diagnosed almost immediately
after your child dies in fact nine
percent of parents who lose a baby in
the United States are diagnosed and
drugged in the first 48 hours right and
it's not to cassia Tory per se we grieve
because we've loved right grief is a
testament to our love it's not a glitch
it's not a pathology it's a profound
form of love if someone you love dies it
is natural and necessary to grieve if
you interrupt that process if you
pathologize the pain if you say you know
it's a sign of good for so for example
one of Joanne's clients you know treats
people with Trump who've gone through
terrible traumatic grief you know one of
her parent one of the parents should
work with mentioned to a psychiatrist
that she when she would lie there at
night she would sometimes hear her son's
voice talking to her not in a
distressing way in fact soothed her
entirely natural form of grieving she
was diagnosed as psychotic and
prescribed loads of antipsychotics you
can see what our eye on eclis what a
crazy system that is that's telling us
we're crazy for having perfectly natural
human responses we do an activity that
we know that it's possibly like weak and
either in the mountain and it's nothing
that we look and we are not doing that
because the
because we are close to this but because
we are alive when we're doing but is the
possibility of of the a of an accident
and and when you have some close calls
it can be like yes some friends that
they die by your side or it can be like
some accidents but all the times I think
it's funny that when you start to do
mountaineering like you are afraid about
your capacities because you don't know
yourself
but you see the mountainous something
solid that it's it's there it's like a
ball or it's something and more you go
into the mountains less you are afraid
about yourself you know better your
capacities your technique your
experience but you see that the mountain
it's moving and it's it's dangerous
there that you you don't see that they
are there so you are more afraid about
the mountain so it's this thing that
it's many things that you cannot control
like you can think logically but then it
avalanches come where it's supposed to
not or like some rock falling and things
and you need to accept in a way that
that's part of it that it's many things
we can control that it's some of them
that is not possible to do yeah I mean I
look at you as somebody who despite all
of your accomplishments you know as is
very humble like you have a very healthy
relationship with humility and not to
project but I would imagine that comes
from an appreciation and respect for
nature like you're never gonna beat the
mountain right and if you don't have a
respect and a healthy level of humility
when you're attempting these challenges
and you're putting yourself at great
peril so keeps you like sort of
right-sized about everything yeah I
think conquering mountains is a very
very ironic
word I think like we are not conquering
mountains up there like we can conquer
itself and the mountain is where we is
this big mirror where we see yourself
but but we can never pretend to
to be fighting against the mountain or
to be finding against nature because
first of all because we are part of it
like we we are part of the nature so I
think it's important to to pass there
lightly so we can only see your four
steps but we like living no trace is not
only like about living rubbish but it's
also about like being being accepted by
the mountain or being try yeah kind of
like being there but trying to turn a
grass the mountain and I think on a way
I don't think that if you turn aggress
the mountain it will respect you more
but at least it keeps you aware of like
okay you are really really nothing you
are very very small even if you are like
and especially because the sport it's so
much about ego and how the sport is
organized like you win a race and you
are in the top of a podium that it's
like it's something very artificial like
why you are better because you run
faster than the guy that is second on
one the one is third or the one is
Laswell so we'd really like building
kind of this egocentric mindset house
powers organized so you can think and
it's easy to believe that you are
someone good or that you are better than
others and especially Montagnes
that's very dangerous on and they're
like it will put in your side like yeah
you are nothing right yeah we are so
much about we want to leave a legacy or
we want to to be remember or we want to
do something important and then nothing
we do it's important like it's yeah it's
is nothing and I think when you realize
that we are not important and what we do
is not important then you realize how
wonderful it is yeah we get so much with
like inertia it it takes a lot of people
today I think like we it's we tend to do
what it's the simple thing the sample
thing and to try to do
what ZZ and what it's supposed to be and
we don't take time to to find what we
want to do and not what we are supposed
to do but they're like when you find
that that's what you want to do want to
find that the the balance on that it's
much like it's just the life it's much
better like everything around it's much
better but yeah I suppose it just like
it needs to you need some courage or you
need some like seeing some time okay I
don't want to that and to be able to say
no I don't want to that and I want to to
cut on things and maybe that means less
medics position or less money or less I
don't know things that they are supposed
to drive you through through success but
they're like how you have you count
success it's very different yeah yeah so
what is living outside the comfort zone
taught you like this this ability to be
comfortable with being uncomfortable
like how is that a teacher for you and
what can be learned from that well I
think it did you it's mostly decision
taking like how to how to take decisions
how you take decisions in the in the
zone like to be always exposed like to
not be sure about what's going on and to
able to be really rational on on seeing
very fast
what are they the different consequences
on each decision you are taking at that
period I think that you can apply on on
life and you can apply on on everything
else and yeah it's I think it's to be a
really cold blood but to be colored to
to follow your your emotions and that's
that's kind of contradictory but they're
like is you want you need to to listen
to your emotion order to listen to your
to yourself to see where you want to go
what's the lifestyle you want to have
what's the things you want to achieve
and that that need to be your emotion
that decides this but then the decision
taking through there you need to be
really like a rational yeah what what
what scares you the most
well many things I would say like of
course like when going out like dying or
like having like a bike accident things
like that but I think what scares me
in more general it's like where where
are we going like the war like now we
see like all the environmental problems
and especially when you are in in in
these areas like with a lot of glaciers
like you can see they were they almost
how it's changing so on this way like
where are we going as as the planet and
that's something that it's it's
scurrying yen and I think that and where
were associated like all the the
problems between humans that we have all
the the with yeah it's a lot of yeah
conflicts human conflicts too and I
think that's that's more scary than not
they're like dying the future of
humanity yeah yeah humanity but humanity
like the yeah we are one species more of
the plants also the planet to you what
is uh what's driving all of this like
where does the motivation come from like
where is the muse like what's what's
behind the curtain here that's
propelling you is it a sense of wanting
to be the best version of who you are is
it a search for excellence or perfection
is it just connecting with nature like
what is the driving impulse for you
I think the driving imposes its
happiness simply it's like to to be
happy and
and that's that's a easy answer but it's
a it's a depends or two because we're if
our happiness is is on one knowing
myself challenging myself and seeing who
I am where I can go and experiencing
different things I think it's a lot
about experience and an experiencing
place is natural
beers like I've run in places that they
are beautiful and that's what it
motivates me to go to one place or
another is too wide to go there it's to
see the beer from that point and see the
the beauty of the natural is one big
motivation and if I can combine that
with with the inner challenge that it
can be be able like to put the question
I am able to progress and like I think
achievement on the sense of like doing
things that you think that they are not
possible for you before like all the
effort you put to be able to change
these status from impossible to possible
so when someone comes to you and says oh
my god look what you build it's so
inspiring but I don't know what my
purpose is I don't know what makes me
passionate I'm not sure which direction
to take like what is the counsel I'm
sure you filled this question all the
time like what daily your counsel to
that in so first and foremost go play go
discover like wander around go to a
different country like encounter enough
stuff that you see what actually gives
you that spark of interest don't expect
a spark of passion doesn't happen like
that you're gonna be interested by
something and that's something will be
maybe a little more interesting than the
next thing that thing now go down the
process of really engaging with it they
go full in so if you were traveling
around India and you went and taught a
you know a week-long math class and you
were like I've never been this fulfilled
in my life moved to India and teaching
the slums for a year and even that were
how about just when you go back home
maybe you know start tutoring kit like
well you don't have to revolutionize
your life overnight
you start bringing greater expression to
that impulse it will lead you in a
trajectory that you can't foresee in
that moment super powerful answer so I'm
a thousand percent with that engaging
with it whatever face that takes but
really spending time that really doing
it then if it turns into a full-blown
fascination we like I really dig this
then we're gonna go down the process of
gaining mastery only in the process of
gaining mastery will you find passion so
to me passion comes out of sky like love
I don't believe that love it needs a
different word unrequited love is a very
different neurological state than
reciprocal love so if you have
unrequited love to me that's something
you really like I love singing but I'm
[ __ ] at it so I have unrequited love I
love singing but singing does not love
me back
now I could go down the process of
gaining mastery and then I may find that
I have a real passion for it
because part of its going to become oh
I'm gaining the skill and this skill of
singing allows me to have an emotional
impact not only on myself but on other
people I can make them feel good I can
change their mood I can tell a story
whatever it is that you want to do with
the music but when you're able to do
with that and you're truly good at it
and it has the outcome that you desire
then it can become a passion but to get
a passion you've got to fight through
just ridiculous amounts of boredom
fatigue everything to truly become good
enough at it that it's a skill that has
utility so when it came to do I buy an
island and retire or do I double down it
came down to what will make me love my
life the most and the reality is the
thing that would make me love my life
the most because it would still be fun
to just go home be with my wife but the
thing that make me love my life the most
is to do the things that are fulfilling
and I think fulfillment has a very
specific Universal formula and that
formula is work your ass off to get very
good at something that you care deeply
about that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it you
got to have all of it technique
literally yes
it is literally technique yeah and
people they don't like what that is for
people that don't know so it's this
ancient Greek notion of fulfillment
basically and the fact that is coming
from that word techne like to get good
at something
and something that's hard so the way
that I explain it to people is people
think of like doing some of that going
and ladling soup at a soup kitchen which
may be the right place to start but
ultimately you're gonna realize anyone
can do this and so I haven't earned
something special that allows me to
serve myself in humanity so it's part of
it is working your ass off to get a set
of skills have real value and my whole
thing here's this maybe the biggest
problem we face as a society people
don't remember that skills have utility
they let you do something you don't
learn to build a house to impress your
parents you learn to build a house so
people can live in the house you build
and once people understand that like
holy [ __ ] you're building this house so
somebody can live in it build a home in
it have a family be sheltered from
storms like [ __ ] it's a real thing man
and so all of that effort and energy
went into I have the chills right now is
so you can create that moment for
yourself for other people it is it is
something so much more than going to
architecture school which maybe you went
to because your parents wanted that and
they they were architects and so you do
that thing for that and you forget the
whole reason you became an architect was
to build houses and so once people
realize oh I'm putting all of this time
and energy to build these things because
they let me do something what do I want
to do what do I want to give what do I
want to create when you look at skills
from that perspective it is like it is
being a superhero it is being a
superhero you're going to collect these
abilities these abilities actually let
you do something the fact that Superman
can fly allows him to save people allows
him to do things other people can't do
we all have this opportunity to become
capable of the extraordinary to be able
to do things other people can't do and
that feels so good
the thing is though most the thing
that's unique about you is that you were
able to come to this realization and
develop a level of maturity and
self-awareness without having to go to
the you know play it out at the
Lamborghini dealership right because
most people who would come into that
kind of wealth would go and have that
experience for a period of time only to
discover you know what you just
expressed but on the other
side of it so why were you able to do
that why were you able to avoid that
experience and circumvent it they say a
fool never learns a smart man learns
from his mistakes and a wise man learns
from the mistakes of others far too
often I've been a fool and have repeated
mistakes over and over and over and but
I really do try to be smart I'm not
usually as wise as I would like to be
and just find that I I learned things
the hard way but I really do learn them
so pain for me is a tremendous
instructor maybe because I hate it so
much and just want to move away from it
but thankfully I don't run from it I
figure out what I did that made me feel
that pain whether it's what I value
myself for or whether it's just hey bad
skillset and you need to address it and
then actually addressing it I think that
everything in life comes down to what
your own value system is so what's your
identity what are your beliefs what are
your values what are your haves what are
your routines when you figure those out
that like if you just gave me a sheet
that told me what those were about
somebody I would tell you what the
outcome of their life is gonna be and
for me implementation being willing to
face the fears the anxieties the unknown
the need to stare at my inadequacies so
I can figure out what skills I actually
need in order to go and do something
because implementation is really a
question of skill set so it that's why
motivation ultimately is going to let
you down it's like you may be motivated
to go do something but let me walk you
through exactly what will happen you're
motivated to try this thing which you
don't know how to do and you suck at it
and so you go do that thing you suck it
hurts your ego because your ego is tied
up in being right being good being
talented worthy all those like permanent
set states that people don't realize are
malleable and so they get stuck in that
it damages a self-esteem so they want to
run in the opposite direction
psychological immune system kicks in
reminds them that that was stupid anyway
why were they worried about even trying
that and so they back off and any one
time doing that's not a big deal it's
just that people do that over and over
and over and over and over and my thing
is that such a predictable pattern in
humanity it's like what do you have to
do to counteract that and the thing you
have to do is emotionally reward
yourself for being willing to take the
steps so okay I know I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna suck at it it's gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt my self-esteem and so
what do I need to do to make sure
I don't trip up over that in a way that
makes me turn and run in the opposite
direction number one stop valuing myself
for being good at something and start
valuing myself for being willing to
learn and really the goal of the book is
to shake up our intuitions about
consciousness as much as possible
because I think if we are able to make
progress if we're able to and the human
brain I think is not capable of
understanding everything and so it may
just fall into that category but if we
can understand consciousness better it
will require that we that we really
challenge some strong intuitions that we
have yeah and I think we're at we're at
that point with regard to consciousness
I like that you say that the human brain
isn't capable of understanding all of
these things I feel like there's a cubic
Flair that that kind of emanates across
the scientific community then that that
that we can indeed understand everything
and perhaps that's true at some future
point or with the I think it's
interesting cuz most science I know and
and typically scientists more than other
people I know are much more willing to
say they don't know something or we may
never know or you know this is this is
deeply mysterious physicists in
particular but scientists in general I
think the messaging that comes out and I
would partly fault the media but I think
it's also just a natural circumstance of
the messaging when we learn something
new it's it's kind of declared as if we
we know all these things and everything
is knowable right but I don't actually
think that's this dance well
particularly with physicists I mean the
more you do I mean it's like it's like
how do you even begin to understand what
these things I've been watching these
wonderful videos of this physicist Nima
our Connie Hamed who's brilliant and
hard to understand but I do my best but
he spends most of his time talking about
how space-time is no longer something
that we think is fundamental that
there's something that's more
fundamental that space-time that
that basically there is no at a
fundamental level there is no space and
time so yeah I mean they're never gonna
get our minds around that even if we can
believe it well time is a is a is a is a
focus of the book and in the later
chapters and I want to get to that but
let's start with let's just let's just
define our terms we're talking about
consciousness like what do we actually
mean so people do use the word many
different ways and it's confusing the
way I'm using the word in the book and
what I think most people mean when
they're talking about the mystery of
consciousness the kind of them
consciousness in the most fundamental
sense is the closest word I can get to
his experience and I use Thomas Nagel
description of consciousness from his
essay called what it is like to be a bat
which is a brain essay and I recommend
from from the 70s and he says in that
essay an organism is conscious if there
is something that it is like to be that
organism and that language for a lot of
people they kind of get it right away I
actually for me that happened I knew
exactly what he meant but the language
really isn't very precise and it can be
confusing so I usually follow that up
with a series of questions especially
for someone who's just says I don't I
don't know what that means to say it's
it's like something and so I'll say is
is there something that it's like to be
you right now and I run through this in
the book and of course whoever I'm
asking week we all know we're having an
experience right we're conscious and
we're having an experience and then is
there something that it's like to be
this book on the table and our intuitive
answer is no and despite what's actually
true in the world the fact that we can
imagine a collection of matter in the
universe that entails no experience at
all the lights are not on from the
inside right that's non conscious
material and then a collection of matter
in the universe like your brain where
there's something that it's like to be
that matter that difference is
consciousness and it's how I'm using the
word in the movement although I do
actually prefer experience I think it's
a little slightly less confusing you
I've been thinking about that definition
over the last week and I can't escape
this sense that it's still reductive in
the sense that we're looking at
experience through our own experience
right we're defining what experience
means only through the lens of what it
means and feels like to be human and it
doesn't leave a lot of space or room for
for contemplating that experience could
take another form that we can't relate
to well I can see oh no I think I think
but that's so that's where I'm talking
at a more fundamental so I think and
that's partly what I try to do in the
book is strip away everything that could
be human like you could you could
radically change an experience but the
fact of an any experience at all and you
know I get into these more far-out
theories but even if you contemplate
that you know a single cell or bacteria
has some minimal level of experience
that you and I could never imagine what
it would like to what it would be like
if there's any experience even the most
minimal experience you could imagine if
there's something it's like then that is
consciousness and that could be
completely unlike any human experience
right it's just whether whether it's
completely dark and dead you know
whether the stars there's there's no
experience there at all it's the
collection of atoms that are doing their
thing but there's nothing that it feels
like at all or or there is yeah well I
yes you know I mean it's in a binary way
once you go from nothing to something
but then of course there's this
gradation of what's possible in an
experience once you have experience but
yeah I think you can you can say that
it's either there or not right the fact
that it exists begs the question of the
evolutionary advantage of having it at
all like what is the reason that we
developed this yeah as opposed to you
know the sort of zombie example that
yeah use in the book yeah no and I think
that's that's a that's a very
interesting question and that's kind of
where I swear my thinking started and
it's early on in the book that I posed
these two questions that I think so I
have two categories of intuitions that I
want to challenge one category is our
intuitions about consciousness itself
and then intuitions that occur in other
areas that are in our lives that
strongly influence on or inform our
intuitions about consciousness and so I
kind of put those into two separate
categories and I start with
consciousness and I just for you know
for myself and in my own notes I just
wanted to get out what are the most
basic strongest intuitions we have about
consciousness and so I asked these two
questions in the book one is is their
behavior we can point to from outside a
system that we can use as conclusive
evidence that consciousness is present
in that system right is there is there
something we can witness from the
outside some physical behavior that we
could say yes any time we see behavior a
B or C that's absolute evidence of
consciousness and I think our intuitive
answer is yes and it's a very strong yes
and even after dissecting this for 15
years my answer is still yes
so an example of that would be I mean
there's so many but I often use you know
my daughter if my daughter's falling
down and she's crying and asking for a
band-aid all of that behavior to me
absolutely signifies that there's
consciousness present right she's having
an experience of pain and and so I
wanted to start there because I thought
this is an important exercise in all
areas of science and this is where our
strongest intuitions are but could we be
wrong is it possible that the behavior
that we think is evidence of
consciousness is not necessarily organs
of consciousness and so you can kind of
go in the direction of AI and imagine we
might in the future create something
that seems like a child who was crying
because she fell down but the lights are
actually not on there's no consciousness
there but I think the flip side of that
is also interesting which is even if we
can come up with behaviors and I could
for myself I can't and I think it's
super interesting that we can't but on
the other side of that we know that
consciousness can be present with no
behavior at all right so you use the
diving bell and the butterfly as an
example have you read that book I saw
you know yeah so that's based on a
writer who had something called
locked-in syndrome where I believe his
was due to a stroke but it can it can
happen variety of ways that damage the
brain like a stroke and it left him
completely paralyzed but with a full
experience of consciousness as full as
our experiences right now as full as his
experience was before the stroke he
could hear see think write a book but he
had no way he was completely paralyzed
except for in his case his left eyelid
there was some mobility left in his left
eyelid and miraculously his caretakers
noticed this and they were able to
develop a way for him to write through
the surra I don't know the exact details
but yeah he's lean language made it was
created a certain letter and then he
would spell out words and and wrote this
beautiful book but so that's a case of
even if we can find behavior there's
this other problem in terms of behavior
which is there can be zero behavior and
still be a tremendous the detailed
experience of consciousness thirteen
year olds right are in this extremely
unique developmental box where their
brains are wildly dysregulated you know
where they're very cocky they're very
easily overtaken by emotion as a
function of neurological development
right there's it just they are caught in
this moment where their emotion centers
have been upgraded but their perspective
maintaining centers have not been
upgraded and so if they become upset the
whole system
you know crashes and what my work feels
like my main aim is so that parents know
the developmental box they're in so when
they're 13 year old walks in the door
and they say one word and the kid loses
it or you know has some sort of meltdown
they can actually have the developmental
perspective of oh okay they're having
you know a meltdown because
neurologically they can't it's not that
this is about some
me and then to try to offer some
strategies for getting through that
moment you know um so I I would say what
I aim you know hopefully is is that you
know I think the the work that
psychologists can do is the more we can
just give parents a perspective that is
neutral developmental you know twelve
year olds are like this thirteen year
olds or fourteen year olds are like that
you know and it doesn't always map
perfectly to on to your own kids ages
then parents can adjust but kids are a
moving target right and and and unless
you have a good memory for your own
adolescence or you know good access to
developmental and information it's very
easy to take them at face value but
that's not really uh appropriate but the
more you can do that then you can you
can sort of uncouple from the emotional
trigger and deep personalize it right we
all have our buttons and you know our
kids know where those buttons are and
they know how to push them and you know
it's taking a lot of a lot of work on on
my part a lot of meditation and
mindfulness work and work that I do in
recovery to just be able to have the
capacity the facility to pause when
agitated not just react and get
emotional about something but just you
know take a beat take a moment and try
to you know cogitate the the neutral you
know best next thing to say or do I
think that's awesome right that's one
reaction I also I want parents to know
like it's okay to get mad at your kids
you know not in a mean nasty way but I
think you know if you don't always have
the wherewithal to not react I think
another way to look at those moments is
to think um you know no one's gonna ever
think our kids are as cute as we think
they are right and and I think there's a
lot to be said for learning at home that
you know if you're a jerk people aren't
gonna like it
you know and they're gonna get angry
sometimes or they're not gonna want to
be with you and so you know in my own
parenting I remember when I had toddlers
so two daughters I would get mad you
know
eventually toddlers may get really mad
right and and I I learned to say to my
daughters you know what I'm actually
getting mad right like I'm asking you
repeatedly to do this thing and I know
I'm being paged but I want you to I'm
getting mad and I'm gonna start to be
mad you know if this goes on and then
when if they continued to be annoying
then when I got mad I felt like you had
fair warning right like so it wasn't out
of the blue so I think there's a place
for anger in family life if a kid has
really been incredibly provocative and
the parent is predictable right and they
know what's coming I also think there's
a lot of value and apologizing to kids
when we screw up right so say we blow it
right and and they didn't have it coming
to me there is no there's a lot of power
and there's a lot of beautiful research
on this about rupture and repair right
there's a lot that happens in a
relationship when a parent comes back to
a teenager and says you know what I
overreacted and I owe you an apology and
I am sorry there's there's a real
there's real growth that happens when
parents can do that what parents can't
do is they can't keep doing it
repeatedly right like I mean that's
where it can fall apart but I'm
definitely a sort of the brand of
psychologist who feels like let me give
you five options for how to react to a
kid because it's gonna depend on so many
contextual factors so sometimes you may
be able to be reserved sometimes you
might just come mad and they shouldn't
be surprised because they always know
that's gonna get you going and sometimes
they didn't have a common and you're
gonna apologize you know but they are
all are available and in the course of
the millions of interactions we're gonna
have we're gonna need them all
yeah and those millions of interactions
you know there's there's there's there's
a scientific way of kind of approaching
that and then there's a very kind of
intuition based you know artistic way of
approaching it's like this dance right
and you have this beautiful analogy of
the swimming pool and it kind of
encapsulates that can you kind of
elaborate on that so this isn't
untangled and it grew out of my
observation that you know teenagers work
to become independent that's their job
the piece that seems to really get
parents is that they don't become just
slightly more independent each day you
know they don't just become a little bit
further and more autonomous each day
that a typical pattern is that um you
haven't heard from your teenager for
three days right if she's barely
acknowledged your existence and then
something goes wrong right and she's
very very upset and so then she comes
seeking the parent right and it may be
that she's needing physical comfort or
just wants to talk and wants to share
things it is not unusual in these
moments where there is actually a
physical like there draping themselves
on you or like cuddling near okay so the
girl may be upset I know the parents
through like ah you know I'm like loving
it absolutely loving it um and then and
then she's gone again right and so in
observing this happening in families the
the metaphor I came up with and it's
slightly belaboured but it does work
really well is that the girl is like a
swimmer and the water is the world and
the parents are the wall that holds the
whole thing together they're the pool
and swimmers want to be out in the water
right I mean they want to be out in the
pool and and with they want to be with
other swimmers they want to be gaining
strength and I've keeps thinking about
this metaphor you know when you're in
the middle of the pool you're not
thinking about the edge of the pool like
that's the furthest from your mind right
but then they get dunked or they get
exhausted or something and they have
that feeling you know I think all of us
maybe can remember this from swimming
lessons or they're like I'm drowning I'm
drowning right so they come scrambling
for the wall which is the parent and
they cling to the parent to get their
breath back okay so the parents loving
it I think that usually what happens for
teenagers is they do have that swimming
pool lesson experience where they're
like oh wait never mind I'm fun you know
and so then goodbye guys
but I think actually it becomes a pretty
abrupt goodbye because they're like I'm
fine and oh my god I'm in my mother's
bed right like this is so awkward
so they shove off right there they push
off in a pretty abrupt way so they may
say and I love this about teenage girls
even my own like that margin of like I'm
mean but not punishable commentary you
know that they make so they may say like
wait did you wear that today right how
you know or something like that like
it's just with like a razor razor blade
precision yes yes and so the parents
repeated experiences
I have no idea where you are oh my god
you're letting me cuddle you you just
kick me in the stomach right and it's
sort of on repeat and so what I wrote
that up for is not because I'm like and
so here's the magic solution to prevent
this because you actually cannot prevent
this and I actually don't want you to
prevent this though I don't think you
kids should be rude you know if they say
something really rude you can say like
that's rude you know we don't talk like
that what I wanted was for parents and
this is exactly what we're talking about
- no this this decor like this is what's
happening this is not meant as a as a
personal rejection your daughter can
breathe again
Nashes on you know to her next thing and
so what my aim in in offering parents is
metaphor it was so that they would save
her when they did get to have those
moments it was this beautiful sunny day
actually this kind of calm day where I
you know had these just tears of joy
rolling down my face it was a back soon
when my best moment so it's kind of like
oh like I made only 23 people I think
have ever done solo unsupported and
unassisted from the coast to the South
Pole 23 24 in history and so just doing
that was like an amazing accomplishment
it's a big moment for me and I'm like
God kind of you know feeling good about
this and then the next day I just get
lit up in this storm and the next 7 or 8
days of like the storms have lasted
previous to this about 1 or 2 days and
then all of a sudden this storm got 7
you know 6 days 7 days 8 days I find
myself you know kind of picking through
this cyst roogie you know day 48 eight
days in this battle with this storm the
wind hasn't been anything lower than 40
50 mile-per-hour was just brutal
conditions and I find myself falling
like really bad to actually fall on the
ground hit the ground super hard and I
remember this one moment i fall in this
big hole and my rope on my harness pulls
tight and then my sled starts sliding
towards me and i'm in this kind of
four-foot hole and I see this sled like
gonna like maybe kind of fall down on
top of me it's like I'm looking where my
leg is but like I can't move it because
the skis are on the ground I'm like wow
like and it's like teetering it's like
this sled falls at me it's like a broken
leg broken ski in a Suzuki storm and
then I looked down and my skin's have
ripped off the bottom of one of my skis
which is impossibly hard to get back on
in this storm and I've only gone for one
hour
and so I'm like okay the only way to get
my skins back on is a set up my tent so
I think to myself okay like I should set
up my tent right now and then like maybe
regroup but I like can't just waste the
day because I am starting to run or
lower on food and certainly you know
trying to stay in the front of this race
and so I set up my tent and there's this
video cup of me where I didn't I filmed
a lot of this stuff my obviously I
filmed it all myself but I filmed a lot
through time and I'm looking in the
camera and I'm just going like I'm
sobbing and I'm like I'm not doing good
like I just want to give up like I'm
like so beat down and this and it was
just kind of in this moment you know two
things for me happened that moment to
get out of that headspace which is
another one of my favorite mantras it's
a simple and that a lot of us have which
is this - shell pass you know
remembering sort of the impermanence of
this moment but also I had this
satellite device that I was pinging to
the satellites every 10 minutes that
people could track me in real time
that's how the New York Times and family
and friends and all these school kids
through a nonprofit we're following
along and you know they see that I've
stopped and a friend of mine
Blake Brinker he he saw that I stopped
and was like wow something must not be
going like well for you like I was
checking in you could set these like
rudimentary text messages to the
satellite device and he sent the text
message and it's a passage from one of
my favorite books which is the alchemist
and he says he says remember the
allegory from The Alchemist that you're
being tested by all the lessons you have
to go through before finally achieving
the ultimate success and he goes don't
forget when passing the alchemist of
course is about the desert but in order
because its own kind of desert and he
says more often than not people die of
thirst when crossing the desert a few
minutes before seeing the palm trees on
the horizon and so it was just this
reminder of like yo like you're in it
like you are getting tested right now
but if you can manage to get back out of
this tent out of this tent remember that
this too shall pass
then you hopefully get to the other side
of this and sure enough on that day it
was tough but you know just taking my
tent up and down in this storm takes an
hour hour and a half and I saw I'd do
that but instead of getting my sleeping
bag out I take my tent down again fix my
skins and get back out and battle
through this storm and manage 20 miles
that day which is a pretty solid mileage
for me on any given day and I think to
me that was both the lowest moment but
also a crux moment where I'm being
tested by all of these things and it
would have been there was a million
reasons to quit in that moment at least
maybe not quit the whole project but
quit and that moment be like I'm falling
I mean get her my sleds gonna follow me
my skins are falling off the storms
lasted a week like I'm starting to get
frostbite on my nose my cheeks like I'm
beat up and I still manage to you know
with the strength is sort of others and
that vibration from family and friends
and supporters is able to kind of draw
some strength and inspiration to keep
going been really kind of the essence of
all of this was how much as humans of
course I'm all alone in this time you
know pontificating about but I'm
thinking about the importance of
community the importance that we all
have to lean in to love one another to
really be compassionate to help to
uplift and support one another and how
much stronger we can be when there's
that you know not this finite level of
love but this infinite love that we can
share with one another and what that can
really create in this universe was was
absolutely spectacular to feel that and
be so viscerally connected to that at
the end of this journey and what does it
taught you about not only your own
capabilities but about human
capabilities in general and and and
potential you know I feel like I
scratched the surface of this you know
11 years ago we've talked about this
before but when I was severely burned in
this fire in Thailand I was told I would
never walk normally and then I recover
from that through the guidance of my
mother's love and positivity ultimately
yeah I'm gonna interrupt you really
quickly here just to share one
reflection on that we have talked about
that and I'm well aware of that story
from that life but this is how weird
memory works yeah in my mind I had this
sense that that had happened way earlier
in your life than it actually had and
when I sort of realized like oh wait
that was 2008 like that wasn't that long
ago that dude that was only 10 years ago
yeah exactly so yeah I was I had been a
collegiate swimmer before that I mean it
kind of gone through a big chapter of my
life and yeah it was you know took a
surfboard in a backpack and scraped
together some pennies after college to
go travel the world and I met Jen at the
very beginning of that trip so that was
a net positive for that who ottoman
became of course the most important
person in my life but not long after
that I found myself in rural Thailand
with the kerosene flaming rope wrapped
around my legs my body lit on fire and
having to dive into the ocean to
extinguish the flames I saved my life
but not before my legs were severely
burnt and spent several months in this
high hospital being told I would
ever walk again normally and in that
moment my mother came she arrived about
the fourth or fifth day and kind of
comes to my bedside and she says like
Collin like visualize your future like
visualized yourself you know being
whatever you want to be you know your
life's not over and I was just in this
deep tragic you know place in my mind
and my body and my spirit and I closed
my eyes kind of trying to you know
placate my mother in some regard and I
pictured myself crossing the line of a
triathlon which is not something I'd
ever done and so I won't get into the
whole story but the you know the next 18
months were kind of learning from that
lesson and keeping this sort of fixed
goal my mind of racing this triathlon
and ultimately you know competing in the
Chicago triathlon as an amateur and
winning my first you know ever triathlon
and my first go at it which was crazy a
crazy moment but the reason I bring that
story up I mean it's important
inflection point in my life which is you
know in that moment I started to feel I
wasn't like wow like I'm so amazing like
I I'm so blessed and so good that sounds
like wow like as humans I believe we all
have these reservoirs of untapped
potential inside of us and can achieve
these extraordinary things when we shift
our mindset for the positive when we're
supported by this loving community of
infinite love and compassion and
positivity like wow like how
extraordinary is that and so that was my
first kind of lesson towards that but I
was you know 22 23 years old and I'm
kind of the beginning of this journey
which has been the last you know decade
of my life in this chapter in Antarctica
certainly not the last chapter of my
life but the most recent chapter of my
life is Antarctica and to connect to
that on such a even even you know 10x or
100x deeper level which is like wow like
what what look at what we are capable of
myself I mean people keep coming back
and I do these interviews and things and
people want to say like Colin like are
you superhuman and I'm like yeah I'm
superhuman and so are you like so are
all of us but just I think it just
happens how we flex this muscle between
our ears is six inches between our ears
like what we can do with their minds is
extraordinary and how we can all be
connected and uplifting each other in
that sense and so for me and an article
the lessons learned were yes about my
own potential but really were resonant
you know across humanity of what we are
all capable when we set our minds things
and again I don't think that necessary
anyone wants to walk across an article
so unsupportive no Nate I don't blame
you for not wanting to do that but like
we have dreams we have goals and it's so
easy to get in
our own ways of stopping the progress
towards that and like when I started
this whole thing like like I said you
know Jenna and I had like no money we
have like a whiteboard on our wall every
reason not to do this and like you
should be like yeah like go get a real
job like grow up like do something we're
like no like what can we do to have
positive impact let's start a non-profit
like let's dare to dream greatly and
like we started out by like taking out
our Mac laptops being like well if we
want people on social media to do this
we better know about marketing I had
like 200 Instagram followers like my
parents and my close friends and we're
googling like Google what's the
difference between marketing and PR like
we're basic of all basic questions you
know but I just got the metrics back on
this last project and we did you know as
of now it's 1.8 billion media
impressions and Counting and I don't say
that because like I care about having
like my name in like the press but
because of that we've created this
platform this ability to share these
stories about inspiration positivity
love
nutrition health all the things that I'm
passionate about and I know from you
from having this podcast itself so a
blessing for you to be able to you know
have this voice not because like you
want to be rich roll this like famous
guy but because you have this
opportunity to share with the world and
the resident positivity that you can put
in the world from that as incredibly
humbling and meaningful and I applaud
you for it I mean you know lasting
impact that's the juice right so what is
the what is the lasting impact that that
you know what is the impact that you
want this adventure and everything that
you're doing going forward to have like
what is the change that you want to see
in the world yeah you know I think that
when I've really tried to drill down to
this I you know I mentioned this before
like sort of this athlete and arena and
I'm a by the way I'm a massive sports
fan like I'm you know I like watching
sports as throughout my life but I think
that our sort of knowledge or interest
in sports in general not always the case
I think like the NBC Olympic coverage is
a great example of not doing this but
often times the sports are like winning
losing like this sort of like the
zero-sum game of like cheering for your
team we're rooting against the enemy or
something like that but you know for me
and doing this it's not so much about
that at all it's about tapping into
these sort of universal truths that we
all face and encounter which is like
facing obstacles stepping outside of our
comfort zone to grow and being an
example of those lessons and showing you
know showing all the flaws like I'm not
sitting here going like yep I stepped
off the plane
I knew I could beat Lou he was not you
know it's like no like I like had this
huge daunting task of crossing
Antarctica oh and by the way like the
most experienced Explorer in the world
it's also out there beside me but I was
willing to like give it a shot which is
I think emblematic of someone starting a
small business everyone going like oh
but like why wouldn't Google or Facebook
just like do the same thing why would
you start with that tech idea like
that's never gonna work or you know the
person that's like starting a family or
has lost a loved one and like just
figuring out how to get on through life
and so hopefully like by sharing my
story as authentically and really as I
can with all the ups and downs and the
struggles and the warts and the
successes that people can take from that
in their own life's what they will and
really impaler masterpieces so what is
the protocol now like how do you make
sure because you've been in you know
treatment centers before yeah and have
seen what has happened when you haven't
had like active you know aftercare and
you know really made your recovery a
life priority yeah you know it that I
mean I think that's the greatest unknown
and that's so you set up I set up as
much guardrails and support as I could
coming back here I started work
initially part-time and then I was still
doing more like an intensive outpatient
so it's kind of doing the to and then
you so you slowly step down and then
right now I have kind of an outpatient
team and then really just setting up a
support network and for me that I have a
great support network but it's making
sure that I actually use it and actually
reaching out of being saying like hey I
need help and this thing that we talked
a lot about that treatment is outing
yourself I'm just saying like hey guys I
have to out myself right now I'm having
really bad disordered thoughts and I
just need to tell somebody and put it
out there cuz when I put it out there
then it doesn't hold as much power over
me yeah and you have to do that in real
time when it's occurring because the
tricky thing is when that moment arises
when you're you know staring at a plate
of food and you're thinking about and
like not eating it away it's too late
like then they're like call somebody but
that that train left the station a long
time ago me
months ago like it's it's about the
daily habit of checking in with people
and people who know you and can monitor
like hey you're a little off today
what's going on and kind of compelling
you to be honest yeah exactly it's
having that support system and network
and and really for me fully owning that
there are some things that I can't be
completely self reliant on right now you
know and and that's a bitter pill to
swallow for somebody who likes to be
fully self-reliant but there have been
times and coming back to the bay area
and coming back to work where I realized
like I need to set up like I need to set
up dinners with folks right now to like
go out and eat with them because it's
better I do much better in like a social
scenario than that then when I'm by
myself in alright well now you're
publicly on the hook I know the entire
world right so it's I mean it's a
double-edged sword because I did have
some people reach out to me and say oh
well now everybody's watching me you you
can't screw up uh-huh
and all of a sudden my heart was like
like I'm human I'm gonna screw up I've
screwed up like we're all gonna ask her
us and I think it's you know with with
alcohol or drugs it's very easy to name
your screw ups because it's like I did
the sub sensor I didn't do the sub sense
food it's very very stubborn not binary
no it's very it's like did I restrict
that meal a little or did I am I really
eating to hunger you know so gotta
really be in touch with yourself and and
you know be willing to have that kind of
honest dialogue going on all the time
like it's about your intentions as much
as anything else right but you know the
the the authenticity and the
vulnerability with which you you know
kind of have offered this up to the
world I think is honorable and and and
super courageous and I don't say that in
a perfunctory or light way like it was I
know it was a move that like you
you know had a lot of consternation
about like should I show you know should
I talk publicly about this you don't
have to you have no obligation to you
made that decision I was on the I went
to the website for Opel because yes this
organization is about and they they had
like a there's like a slogan on the
homepage that is beauty in imperfection
and authenticity and that's lovely right
because we're all imperfect and I think
the the path towards being that fully
integrated person who's not living with
that kind of dissonance requires you
know the courage to be authentic in real
time you know and to be human and to be
you know exposed on some level and you
know I can't imagine what it felt like
after you wrote that blog post and you
like hit you know publish on it like
walk me through that it was actually the
most freeing experience and I've ever
had I sat down and I bawled my eyes out
for the next half an hour or so as you
were writing it or after you after I
said I mean I thirst this the catharsis
cuz I had been writing it you know over
like a span of since I mean I left
treatment at the end of June and then it
so it took me like a few weeks to kind
of wrap my brain around it and I was so
anxious I remember that day before I was
like going to publish it it was all done
it was steady you know it was ready to
go and I remember actually going to the
pool to swim that morning and then just
like was like the best one my life
because it was just like anxiety or
something like that I don't know fueled
but in in putting it out there it
finally I just I cried because it was
just I finally felt true to myself
mm-hmm and what was the motivation
behind doing that honestly a lot of it I
hate to say that there was a selfish
motivation because it was it was almost
a
an alignment for myself yeah you know
people are like oh would you were you
you're so great you're inspiring other
people and I'm like that's okay
discomfort of living in that kind of
dissonance becomes intolerable exactly
and and I don't I can't say why exactly
I felt the need to a load it to the
entire world as opposed to just because
I understand there are portions of
yourself that you can keep close you
know and you don't have to let everybody
know your dirty laundry but for me it
was very important to have that be a
part of my story considering I've been
so open and vulnerable about many other
things but not this and then that kind
of selectiveness didn't sit well with me
right and just to be able to be feel
free I felt very very free after I
apologized I went for a run the next day
and I was like I was the most just free
feeling and then people started giving
me negative feedback and then that went
away don't you yeah well 24 hours was
great I don't know I'm sure yeah well
look first of all shame can't survive
the light right so whatever shame you
were harboring the only way out of that
is to do exactly what you did and I'm
sure there's trolls out there whatever
but like all I saw was this overwhelming
like outpouring of like love and support
like it was like it would be it was like
a viral moment in the in the endurance
sports world I did I honestly will say I
expected a reaction I did not expect
that type of attention to it and I'm
blown away in the best way possible I
mean I I was it was amazing like I mean
I get kind of like choked up thinking
about it because people were so
supportive and so great I'm still like
sorting through emails to respond to
people and I think
for me it was very important to talk
about it to you at a time where I have
not recovered and and that was that was
that's a bit tough because I think that
you see so many people talk about their
disorders in the past or their
addictions in the past but it comes from
a recovered perspective and I you know I
got a lot of feedback saying like thank
you for being open before you're there
you know because it's not as simple as
that and and I go back and forth on
whether like total freedom as possible I
feel like the voices get quieter like
things like they get easier the further
and further like you get into recovery
but I think that you always kind of have
to be vigilant and I maybe you can speak
to that - yeah I mean I'm of the mind
that that there is no recovered
there's recovery there's being active in
your recovery I would never consider
myself recovered ya know and and you
know I had a relapse eight years ago
after I'd been sober for thirteen years
like I'm very aware of how fragile it is
and how how it requires you know
constant attention and focus and you
know that's not to say that you know
your situation is the same you know it's
different but I would be curious about
it like is there a sense like that there
is a recovered when it comes to
relationship with food I just feel like
that impulse is always there and and
keeping it at bay you know is important
and there's tools for doing that but to
fall under the belief that it could
disappear altogether and never reappear
I think is dangerous yeah I think
there's different mindsets
um I think some people think that if you
don't give if you don't believe and that
fully recovered is possible then you
know you're never going to get there but
I maybe this might be more of the
unpopular opinion but I do kind of
similarly believe to what you do is that
you know like you can be in a very very
good place of recovery
but you still need to be mindful of
things and especially the longer you
know like this has been 20 years of my
life and a lot of this stuff has become
so ingrained and automatic in me
and so it's almost in some ways like
exposure therapy and unlearning habits
and things like that that didn't happen
overnight you know yeah and it's all
about where you are in the moment like
my relationship with this is like what
am i doing today like where where is my
recovery like in the middle of this
experience that we're having right now
because I know people with 30 days of
sobriety who like our super sober and I
know people who've been sober for 35
years who are out of their minds right
they may not drink but they're not they
don't have they don't have like
emotional sobriety which is really kind
of like where there's no there's no
there's no destination for that because
you can always hit rate and improve on
you know who you are as a human being so
it's less about where are my cravings
for alcohol right now then than it is
about like what's up with my character
defense I like being married to my wife
like I don't want her to leave like sigh
I have to like be on top of this [ __ ]
it's funny when as soon as as soon as I
started to realize that like the food
was no longer like the scary issue and I
was god now I have to work on myself
right it's like now I have to like kind
of like underbelly things that is the
point versus driving you like this is
this is all about that right and I and I
think my big thing is that I I'm a
thinker and I've always like no no no I
know my feelings for so many years I was
really good at thinking about my
feelings like really really good at like
thinking about my feelings but not
actually feeling anything and I think
that actually in our society we prize a
lot of thinking over feeling you know a
lot of people who fall like the stoic
like philosophies and things like that
and and once I finally start to like tap
into what am I feeling right now and
like then just like not even not even a
signing and like not assigning judgments
to that but and then just actually like
being like feelings are valid too it
doesn't all have to come from the
morning
our culture has shifted and changed the
gatekeepers are gone the tools of
creativity are more accessible than ever
there's a more there's a democratization
of this universe that didn't exist back
then that makes that I think has
stimulated and motivated and inspired a
lot of people to think about creative
creativity more broadly you know that
and and whether that means quitting your
job to be an artist or just finding a
hobby or like you know being intentional
about the images you put on Instagram
sure these are all aspects of creativity
and and and really what you've done is
broaden the aperture on what creativity
means while also underscoring the
importance of it in everyday life for
everybody no matter who you are if you
took that away I am done no that's
examined literally you just sort of like
you know I don't even need to introduce
the book because that is the the ethos
behind the book that was you know
specifically broadening the aperture on
creativity because right now there's
people going away I don't know if I'm
not really identified as creator I'm an
attorney or I'm an accountant to him
whoever's listening it's like no no this
is exactly why and if you're if you're a
creator you identify as that great this
is like right in your sweet spot but
there's a whole universe of people who
are what I call creative curious that
understand that there's some power there
that I can't kind like the Genesee quo I
don't know how to grab on to it and I
want to understand that a little bit
more and when you broaden that
definition of what creativity is which
to me is part of the challenge that
we've had historically with how art and
creativity have been viewed in our
culture when you broaden the aperture a
little bit you can also then sink your
teeth into it and find immense and
powerful meaning mm-hmm yeah I think
historically the word creative or
creativity isn't necessarily pejorative
but it's exclusionary people either
identify with that or they don't or
they're scared of it yeah and in truth
it is it is part and parcel of what
makes us human
it is a universal aspect of the
condition of being in one of these
bodies yeah literally we are creating
machines and that's part of like
expanding the definition to understand
that wait a minute you know that my
decisions on which how to get to your
house today do I go here this way or
that way the would I you know decide to
do with my day in my time on a on a
minute-by-minute basis but also on a
life scale basis like those are all
wickedly wildly creative acts that have
been discarded into like you know if you
were thinking of a mineral pathway it's
just like the base neural pathway that
you always go but there's an opportunity
for in all of those places to do
something different and when you start
to realize that this creativity in small
daily doses is the same exact muscle
that we use to create our life it's just
creativity different scale your head
starts to go like okay ready to pay
attention here right well so then if I
was to ask you how you define creativity
what is the response to that it's such a
the way that I approach it is so simple
it may be painful for some people but
it's the act of putting two things that
might not have gone together just a
moment ago of putting those two things
together to create something new and
useful mm-hmm so it is a very broad
definition but that's to me what
actually makes the book really relevant
because there are people like this is
not about changing your lifestyle this
is not about moving to Barry and wearing
a beret and smoking a cigarette in
Canada if that's your deal totally it
can be but it's also doesn't have to be
about a new set of friends instead it's
a new way of operating it's a new way of
seeing what's in front of you and you
know just at a super top level it's like
I operate from the principle that a
every person is creative that it's the
thing that separates us from every other
species on the planet
and it is it's fun I'll just walk into
any first grade classroom right who
wants to come at the front of the room
and draw me a picture every hand goes up
and then do the same thing with the
sixth-grade class and then a ninth grade
class and you see that we're this is a
thing that is innate and we're training
it out of us so if if that's principle
one principle two I'm sorry one is that
where's creativity every person two is
the creativity is a muscle it's a habit
not a skill it's a process not a product
it's a muscle and I guess Maya Angelou
said it well like the more you use the
more you have right think about training
or anything else right so it becomes
more available to us and then if you
follow one and two the simple argument
number three is so then all these small
creative acts that we do every day yes
playing the guitar making a meal
building a family writing code yes those
things are literally the things that are
going to give you the insight that you
have agency / creativity with a capital
C like creating the arc of your life
mm-hmm so to me that like it's from a
very simple definition you just have to
make a simple three-step argument and
all of a sudden you're at this like I
need to pay attention yeah that
creativity is a non depleting renewable
resource that it's not something that
certain people are struck with but that
they cultivate through a deliberate and
intentional practice over time yeah that
is divorced from the results of it and
all about the process of doing like it's
not fake it till you make it it's make
it till you make it so the process of
being a maker in whatever form that is
for you yeah yeah and when you think
about it like let's let's talk about it
away from the sort of small C creativity
of making a meal or building a business
or whatever and talk about it on the
life scale the people that you are
inspired by that you moved by that
you're connected to that you admire
their lives were created intentionally
there's all kinds of circumstances but
they created the puzzle that is their
life and they're they're expressing
themselves in a particular way it's
intentional it's designed and it's
created it's not just you just fell into
this thing one day and right and so when
you start to look at creativity with
that sort of capital C on the life arc
you're like who who do I am and it
doesn't need to
be someone famous or fancy in the
internet or or some you know well known
entrepreneur artist it can be your
next-door neighbor that lives in amazing
integrity and and they have a
mindfulness about them then you really
like that's not on accident that was
created that person set out with a
vision for themselves and slowly but
surely got there there was no overnight
there was no it was a creative process
and that's available to you yeah this is
why I advocate action over intellect
like if you're sitting around trying to
figure this out and make the perfect
chess move like that's not how it
happens you make a lot of little
imperfect moves you learn a little bit
of a lesson and then you move on just
trying to make the same mistake more
than you know one or two times
ideally one but it's the action it's the
doing that actually creates the learning
it's very hard to and it's it's great to
get information from the internet or
your mentor or whomever but learning
like actually doing that part is
incredibly valuable what needs to be the
takeaway from this talk is whether you
are all in on this or you're just
deciding if you're gonna put your toe in
the water amazing time and it just so
happens that this corresponds with it is
the riskiest time in the world to play
it safe because whatever you were sold
is safe now that's beige it's vanilla it
is you you it's not like you'll blend in
in a good way it's you're leaving so
much on the table in terms of identity
earning power connection with other
people
vulnerability authenticity like if
you're not sort of participant of not
participate yeah especially as we we
progress towards this AI you know
society that's gonna commandeer a lot of
those jobs
[Music]